good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight this is the 13th night
in a row we have led this show with the
Brett Kavanaugh story and it looks like
after delays and countless twists in the
saga it may finally be coming to a
conclusion the FBI investigation one
that Senator Jeff Flake demanded last
Friday appears to be wrapping up a final
vote could be held this weekend that's
what they're saying but what's
remarkable is that after all we have
learned there are still basic questions
that remain unanswered central ones that
pertain directly to the core allegations
here the ones that Christine Ford made
more than two weeks ago yesterday for
example Fox News obtained a written
declaration from an ex-boyfriend of
Christine Ford's in that declaration
which was made under oath
the ex-boyfriend says that Ford once
coached a friend through a polygraph
exam to help her get a federal job if
true that would contradict what Ford
told Congress the man also says that
during their entire six-year
relationship Ford never mentioned being
a victim of sexual assault or of any
other kind of trauma he says that she
flew on airplanes many times including
on small prop planes around Hawaii
you'll recall that her lawyer said she
was too afraid to fly to come to
Washington they also said she was a
claustrophobic he claims she was not at
all afraid of enclosed spaces are these
claims true we don't know for disputes
them and there is no evidence to support
them independently but there's also no
evidence you'll remember to support
Ford's allegations against Brett
Kavanaugh and that is the point we need
to know more but we don't know more
because nobody is asking these questions
and many other questions for example we
still haven't seen Ford's therapy notes
or the notes on the polygraph exam she
says she took for his legal team is only
now at the very last moment offering to
reveal these but only at the FBI agrees
to interview Christine Ford why weren't
these notes turned over at the very
beginning of all of this if the goal was
to get to the truth they would have been
of course why his Ford apparently told
different stories about whether she
showed her therapy notes to the
Washington Post or simply described
their contents to the paper that's
significant because it bears directly on
her credit
ability and christine force credibility
is literally the only reason to believe
that her story is true
so that matters and there of other
obvious unanswered questions here's this
one ford says the assault defined her
entire life apparently she thought about
it every day it defined her academic
performance it affected all of her
personal relationships and yet she says
she told not a single other human being
about it for fully thirty years how can
that be well here's an idea in a
washington post profile ford says that
she quote came to understand her assault
in the significance during a
psychotherapy session what does that
mean exactly is ford's story at least in
part a recovered memory this is a
central question because most
psychiatrists consider recovered
memories however sincere as roughly as
reliable as dreams it's worth getting a
clear answer on that but so far nobody
has because nobody has asked that
question why is that when an adult makes
a serious allegation asking real
questions is the only correct response
it's not an attack to ask for follow-ups
or probe inconsistencies it's not victim
shaming in fact it's patronizing not to
we don't consider christine ford a child
many of our advocates clearly do the
press obviously does instead of
gathering facts about this story they
are busy moralizing and lecturing the
rest of us about how Brett Kavanaugh has
very existence proves that an entire
class of people is evil just the other
day Donald Trump jr. made the point that
what he's been watching on television
makes him fear for his sons watch so
when I see what's going on right now
it's scary who are you scared most for
your son's your daughter I mean right
now I'd say and my son's I mean I want
to bring my daughter's have to be tough
at every situation is different but I
would hope that they would act if
something terrible like that happened
but when the other side weaponized is it
against men and says you know forty
years later we can bring it up and you
did something in high school that no one
remembers but it should disqualify you
from ever doing anything again it really
diminishes the real claims now maybe you
agree with that maybe you don't it's
hardly a crazy point though and it might
be worth talking about but no over on
Cena and they took those remarks as a
cue to
once again attack an entire ethnic group
on the basis of ethnicity watch this
every night I cry myself to sleep over
the fate of white man in America white
men have no power white men I mean it's
such garbage
if you sexual assualt sexually assault
someone in high school your life should
be ruined all this whining about the
poor plight of white men is ridiculous
you're hearing a lot of this filth
recently and it's wrong because racism
is always wrong no matter who it is
aimed at you should not attack people
for their immutable characteristics
period we have made that point
consistently again and again over the
past two years on the show you shouldn't
ever reduce people to their skin color
because they're much more than that
you ought to treat people as individuals
unique human beings not faceless members
of a tribe sorted by hue that's exactly
the argument you could have made in 1960
against Bull Connor and if we'd been
there we would have made that argument
it's the same argument we are making
today it was true then it is true now it
always will be true
now you wouldn't think you'd have to say
something that obvious in a developed
country one that literally has a statue
of Martin Luther King on the National
Mall but we do have to say that we have
no choice and for the crime of arguing
against racism
we are denounced by the left as yes
racists well that's insane in fact it's
Orwellian it's the mirror image of the
truth but there is a reason that they
are saying it our elites stoke race
hatred in order to divide this country
against itself people are easier to
control when they are divided into
tribes sorted by color it is that simple
there's also that evil just like the
racism they are peddling to you we will
never endorse that against any group at
any time period